uh this is something that's good it's
not that stupid debate stuff but there's
something that sounds that's a little
concerning to me
pan this morning a nuclear plant
destroyed by an earthquake and tsunami
back in 2011 started releasing water
that had been exposed to radiation into
the Pacific Ocean it's a release that
follows months of debate and strong
opposition from fishing interests you
say this is very bad for business and
China has already reacted by banning all
Seafood imported from the country of
Japan Elizabeth Palmer visited the site
earlier this year
experts for tepco the company in charge
explained they've collected okay but
like the experts are the re
why didn't the experts stop it from
leaking when it first did so much well
to be fair that like most of the time
those accidents are avoidable this was
like an earthquake in a tsunami that
kind of did it so it's kind of you know
honestly you should be ready for a
tsunami if you're a nuclear plant like
Three Mile Island in Chernobyl was more
of a whoops three mile Line's not even
real you know it's only like two and a
half miles
it's all a [__] psyop folks because
the Earth's really flat so the map makes
it look like it's a three mile you guys
are such idiots honestly but yeah those
were those were the whoops of daisies
those were the oh yeah Larry left a
valve open and uh sorry about that but
Fukushima was a little different because
it was just them they were all just
working one day and they went hey what's
that tidal wave coming towards us
rain and runoff over the years they kept
having to add tanks to contain it I know
I've been playing a lot of City skylines
lately and it's so annoying I'm Gonna
Keep it I have to keep adding more
things why don't they just add the mods
easier if you add the mods as Japan
tried adding the mods if you just
download the large water pumping yeah
yeah yeah you don't have to place like
50 of them these guys are so stupid
watch real civil engineer he teaches me
all that stuff Japan has to install
Nexus mods it's a whole thing you know
what I don't have the time that's that's
that's that's tweet civil engineer to do
that to clean up the [__] radioactive
he would do it he would do it too these
tanks are almost full of water more than
a million tons of it and tepco says the
only solution is to start getting rid of
it and by getting rid of it I mean
dumping it into the ocean yes
it's probably good for the ocean by
piping it bro we're gonna get Godzilla
for real oh we're not we're just gonna
get Blinky from The Simpsons we're just
no we're not even gonna get that we're
just gonna get a bunch of dead fish
floating at the top of the ocean and
cancer yeah that's fun yeah we know it's
never we never get the fun RoboCop
outcome like there's never like a oh you
know Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles it's
just gonna be four dead turtles and a
dead rat floating at the top of a
[__] poisonous super dead fish that's
all you get you know what I was singing
today and I was said it earlier today
but why do the ninja turtles have
California accents if they were raised
in New York well no they don't all have
Raphael the New York accent Michelangelo
has the Cali accent and then the other
two have like flat midwesterners why
different voice actors don't give me
real answers this is not a show where we
give real answers you know that you know
very well that we don't give real
answers on this show oh [__] man but
it's true they all were raised by
Splinter they should have all sounded
like Japanese immigrants yeah they
should have oh thank you
[Music]
who's been fishing this ocean all his
life that is an outrage it's not a
garbage are all Japanese people either
like nuclear reactor scientists or
fishermen like there's no in between no
that's it oh they're also salary men you
could also be the guy that like that
folds the paper the origami guy those
guys
that's a job say it's safe but the
consequences could be 50 years down the
road
there will be no consequences says tepco
because its technology removes all
radioactive compounds from the water
except one
oh except one oh tritium the one that
glows so that's good
which stays in but is diluted to meet
International standards wow that's great
as long as there's International
standards as long as it's a standard I
don't know guys hey fun fact guys you
know what tritium is so you know uh you
know those sites in a handgun that glow
and they last for like ever
yeah those are Dutch tritium
I'm sorry you know I believe in the
Second Amendment you don't want Dolphins
to have tritium sites that many people
know that that's what they make High
School Ecto Cooler out of
so if I drink tritium
I'll have laser eyes
you'll have actually no eyesight yeah
you'll go blind from the radiation
so even when the water is piped back
into the sea tepco says Dr Howie by the
way is being a kind of a spurge he goes
10 years not forever I get it buddy it's
just a Jesus Christ did you come here
for [__] insightful that's actually
true to him so I'd start to dim and then
after 10 years or not yeah okay 10 years
for a sight to last us forever
we'll be safe to eat the international
atomic energy what if he dies in 10
years that's forever for him you didn't
think about that
it's Asia the fish could walk out of the
water with human legs they'll still
[__] eat it it's the tritium it's
like the market from It's Always Sunny
or they're like are they just trading
fish for other fish yeah so they get
fish in those markets and what they do
is to do side hustle they they rub them
on girls panties and sell them in
[__] videos it's not bad we have
monkey will consumers actually eat the
fish unlikely says
who is now looking at the end of his
livelihood
so you guys don't want radiated fish it
seems like people you can't make people
you know what Mercy there's there's a
boomer tweet for you for your engagement
back in my day I'd eat a uranium fish no
problem these kids today are weak
these kids steady a week so what's the
matter you don't want to eat [__]
we're already eating radioactive oil
covered fish what are you talking about
sounds so good
hey Virgie we got any radioactive oil
cover fish back there